Matt is in st. Paul Minnesota hey Matt
your question for Rachel hey there how
are you guys today better than I deserve
how can we help you oh yeah so me and my
wife we've been we're currently on bs1
and in the past probably about five
months we've been sort of getting better
at her our budgeting and with my over
time that I got previous I just put it
towards her credit cards so I got a few
of those paid off and a few days ago I
was going through just our bank
statements and I saw that one of our our
couple characters that I know that we
paid off there was a payment going to
and I asked her about it and she almost
just started tearing up and saying it's
her fault it's you know I'm sorry she
said I'm sorry I have over the credit
card debt and I pretty much just hugged
her and I told her that we'd get through
it and she caught him up but she said
her reason abusing them was when we were
moving mean it is like extra supplies
and she felt like that's like her
security blanket so I'm trying to figure
out ways on how to move her in the other
direction
it sounds like you're making good
progress yeah mmhmm yeah I would say so
the only thing I'm hearing Matt and how
you're talking is saying things like her
credit cards or seeing her statements
and so yeah I'm sorry I misunderstood
she was the thing she was telling me I'm
sorry my credit card debt and I pretty
much told her that when we got married
we were one so now it's our credit card
yeah that's awesome well that's always
gonna say has encouraged you guys on an
emotional level to have that unity so
there's not that separation how long
have you guys been married we just
celebrated three years left in November
yeah that's awesome so you're kind of
starting out this journey and learning
as you're going so yeah I would say to
to again change those pronouns and for
you guys to emotionally commit okay
we're in this together and for her yeah
I mean the number one fear for women
when it comes to money is the lack of
security so for that being her safety
net that's a real
thing and you as a husband I want you to
recognize that which apps can he take
that give her some security from your
perspective well I would say the
thousand dollar emergency funds and
where you may disagree is depending on
how much debt you guys have holding it's
gonna take you off for her and depending
on how old your kids are if you guys are
gonna have another if you're gonna have
a child soon like depending on stage of
stages of life
I think women need more money to feel a
little bit more secure so maybe that
thousand dollars you bump it up to
fifteen hundred maybe you put a little
bit more in the emergency fund for tahat
for her to have that and then as you
guys are looking to pay off your debt
how much debt do you have around fifty
four thousand okay what's your take-home
pay our take-home pay every two weeks as
our own 2,400 okay okay
so what I would say is to map that out
and show her like visually hey here's
the plan of getting out of day and we're
gonna be able to be out of debt in
whatever that is for you guys 12 months
18 months and show her the end because I
think seeing the end of the light and
knowing that that fully funded emergency
fund is coming sooner is going to give
her that safety so it's just I think one
other thing you can do is she's not
involved enough in the budget her vote
has not been solid in the budget and the
budget has not been solid where every
dollar had an assignment and you were
both in complete agreement and if it's
wrong we can come back and change it
kind of a thing and so what happened was
she got hit with the unexpected expense
and instead of running back to the
budget where she felt like she had a
vote and the two of you could change it
to cover those expenses she hit it on a
credit card mm-hmm and so if she feels
more secure in her ability to you two
working together on this budget and even
changing it if something unexpected
comes up you can go back and change the
budget but if she had felt open to do
that she wouldn't have slipped around
and done the credit cards and that tells
me that her vote right now in her mind
is not counting and it also tells me you
guys aren't doing the budget completely
you're kind of making a soif at it
instead of every dollar as a name so get
that app out because even in the budget
there's gonna be a miscellaneous
category that is those
so that's a little bit of the safety net
month-to-month security if I see how
everything is gonna be covered yeah and
if there's something pops up I can come
in and have another discussion that's a
level of security right that's that'll
help her feel secure